[Musique]
ce jour là la modeste façonne de
l'aéroport châteauroux centre ne laisse
rien transparaître de l'événement qui
s'y déroulent la salle d'embarquement de
l'aérogare bruisse de la présence de
voyageurs un peu insolite
invité par la compagnie aérienne ige
avions et aérocentre l'association des
professionnels de l'aéronautique au vol
inaugural de la toute nouvelle liaison
châteauroux toulouse
[Musique]
merci merci
le temps de franchir à pied la courte
distance qui sépare le bâtiment de
l'avion et les 34 voyageurs de saab 340
s'installe
oh tu
on a toujours un
que
un avis
qui s'emballe
il y a
ce vol était très attendue de ceux qui
depuis des années se bat pour le
développement d'un outil trop longtemps
laissée en jachère
c'est une grande joie de voir en pas
l'utilisation
plus abouti de cet aéroport vers des
destinations qui ment
qui vont réjouir les les mairies chaud
comme je l'espère les toulousains pour
celle ci ce serait formidable également
que les corses les niçois demain puisse
dire qu'il se sent bien chez nous qui
sont des des choses est
à y voir et à y découvrir mais c'est
certain que nous avons des aussi des
richesses a présenté notre territoire
est différent d'un pointu aéronautique
une
très belle richesse et vous ou bien vont
les running
les voyages d'affaires pour la
pour le tourisme en général à peine le
temps de savourer un plateau repas
fabriqués localement et l'avion roule
déjà sur les pistes de l'aéroport de
toulouse blagnac le trajet aura duré 70
minutes
[Musique]
à la grande satisfaction du premier
client payant de la ligne moi je
travaille pour la société d'air quitte
une entreprise à sous traitant
aéronautique basé un petit peu partout
en france et notamment dans la région
centre est donc aujourd'hui de partir de
la région centre pour pouvoir arriver
directement à toulouse via le vol du
château c'est vraiment une bonne
opportunité pour notre entreprise
ça serait bien que ces vols puissent
devenir régulier pour que l'ensemble des
jeunes entreprises puissent en
bénéficier dans la navette qui relie à
l'aérogare premier débriefing sur la
perception du vol
est une très bonne prestation
effectivement petit bol donc agréable
[Musique]
je dirais qu'après au niveau du service
à bord très bien aussi et puis c'est
vrai que c'était ce départ de
châteauroux
très bien pour la clientèle avec un
aéroport à taille humaine une compagnie
des petits appareils donc très agréable
aussi et puis avec un parking gratuit au
départ de châteauroux dans via la
clientèle effectivement
très très demandeur de
de ces départs que j'avais l'aérogare
est situé à 2 minutes à peine des
installations d'airbus et permet aux
voyageurs de rejoindre les embarquements
des 90 destinations quand frau toulouse
blagnac châteauroux figure désormais
parmi elles
[Musique]
dalleau
quelques semaines auparavant le premier
vol international châteauroux londres
était lancée cette année six
destinations seront offertes au départ
de la capitale de l'art une stratégie
d'entreprise qui peut déconcerter dans
le credo des dirigeants a toujours était
jusqu'à présent opposée à cette vocation
pour la structure
[Musique]
dominique roullet le président du
conseil d'administration assumera le
changement de stratégie et le coup c'est
une opération de huit cent mille euros
donc là moi je suis très transparent par
rapport à sa façon si vous voulez qu'on
aéroports les vols passagers
ça coûte de l'argent plus vous faites de
passagers plus ça coûte d'ailleurs à
tour ces trois millions d'euros des
collectivités
on n'en est pas là puisque la civic sir
les 800000 ce qui était souhaité ces 90
milles de l'agglo de châteaux ou de
bourges 90000 de l'indre et du cher
la ccit de l'indre et du cher ont des
difficultés qu'on connaît
on a leur soutien et même soutien
financier à hauteur de 10000 euros
c'est modeste mais c'est un soutien de
la ccid de l'indre et le reste sera
supporté par l'aéroport de châteauroux
et par la région centre
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
tél
cette stratégie de mise en lumière d'un
outil performant auprès du plus grand
nombre le maire de châteauroux et
président de châteauroux est trop paul
il souscrit pleinement subventionner le
transport aérien fait partie du
challenge tous les modes de transport
sont subventionnés les transports
urbains les bus sont subventionnés
particulièrement châteauroux les bus
sont gratuits quand vous prenez le train
le prix du billet c'est pas le prix du
coût du service
ces transports sont subventionnés
également il n'est pas anormal que
transports aériens soient subventionnées
on parlait d'une activité économique
avec la maintenance et le fret sur
l'aéroport mais le fait d'avoir des
lignes passagers c'est une vraie plus
value économique
ça veut dire que vous allez pouvoir
permettre à des entreprises de votre
territoire d'aller voir leurs clients de
démarcher des nouveaux marchés de se
développer de créer de l'emploi ici à
châteauroux et puis vous allez pouvoir
attirer sur votre territoire des
professionnels qui vont venir ici parce
qu'il y à cette ligne d'avion et on sait
que dans les dix vingt trente années qui
viennent l'explosion du trafic aérien
quelque chose d'acquis au delà de ça
c'est aussi entrer dans un circuit
international de transport aérien avec
vous avez pu le constater ces derniers
mois une réalité c'est que ne se
construiront plus en france au moins
deux nouveaux aéroports et les
territoires qui en ont doivent en
profiter un maximum au conseil
départemental de l'indre qui n'exerce
plus de compétences économiques
la décision était prise d'aidé à la
diffusion des atouts du berry car là
aussi les lignes voyageurs sont des
portes ouvertes sur d'autres horizons
dans les deux sens effectivement demandé
une participation comme nous on l'avait
demandé d'ailleurs l'année dernière on
et 40-0 que nous avons effectivement
octroyés pour procéder intervention ceci
étant les compétences sont telles qu
aujourd'hui je n'ai absolument pas le
droit de subventionner d'aidé au
subventionnement des sièges d'avion
donc je ne peut intervenir que sur le
côté touristique et donc j'ai proposé au
président bono que l'entreprise qui
copiait dennis crowley
en dix ans faisons comme les dernières
photos d'un montage comme on peut faire
de la communication
déry
emine aux amis du cher et de l'indre
pour la région qu'on me fasse de cette
communication aussi bien à biarritz à
nice en corse à lyon à toulouse fait
beau ce montage vous me demandez 90
mille autres participations
je vous les accords mais je tiendrai ma
promesse simplement l'éclat ils
économisaient pas compétent je ne
parlais que sur l'aspect touriste
l'aéroport châteauroux centre appartient
la région qui doit arbitrer des choix
parfois difficiles de stratégie de
développement économique et de services
aux habitants
l'aéroport déjà de château appartient à
la région et on est aux membres du
syndicat qui gère l'aéroport de tours et
on est en train de définir d'ici la fin
de l'année 2018 une politique
aéroportuaire pour la région parce qu'il
ya plein d'autres plates formes à porte
aéroportuaire dans la région qui sont
intéressantes et il faut combiner cela
il faut qu'on ait une stratégie qui soit
cohérente sur le territoire pour l'heure
l'aéroport entend maintenir le cap d'un
développement raisonné dans lequel le
trafic voyageurs a une incidence minutes
c'est une activité marginale en 2017 ça
a représenté un petit peu moins de 3% du
chiffre d'affaires de l'aéroport
et cette année il ya plus des lignes
vous vous montez un peu on va monter un
peu j'avoue je ne sais pas trop parce
que j'espère aussi que les autres
activités vont se développer
donc je ne pense pas qu'on atteigne des
pourcentages très au-dessus de 5% ça me
semble être un pourcentage qui sera mon
année maximum car l'aéroport de
châteauroux centre ce n'est pas que
l'une des cinq plus grandes pistes de
france grâce à sa très grande emprise
foncière 450 hectares à ses
installations hérité de son passé est
améliorée depuis des décennies il a
permis l'installation d'entreprises
liées à l'aéronautique
c'est en 1936 que marcel bloch créer une
première résine
liés à ce domaine en 1951 elle us air
force s'installe sur le site pour y
implanter sa plus importante base
aérienne
8000 américain jusqu'au départ en 1976
céder à l'état français la plateforme
passera par les mains de plusieurs
gestionnaires institutionnels
en 2007 l'état transfère la propriété et
la gestion au conseil régional
sa destination plateforme industrielle
de fret de formation pour les pilotes
après plusieurs années d'attentes la
vocation industrielle de châteauroux
centre devrait connaître un nouvel essor
nous surplombe on la première plate
forme qui a été préparé pour accueillir
le premier hangar de maintenance dont
les travaux devraient démarrer à la fin
de cette année pour une livraison fin
c'est un hangar qui a vocation à
accueillir des entreprises de
maintenance aéronautique et ou de
peinture en aéronautique donc à
l'évidence on a aujourd'hui un gros
problème de manque de hangars de cette
nature de cette taille sur le territoire
national donc il est certain que des
entreprises vont venir dès que le
bâtiment sera disponible pour rien
porter une activité et créer de l'emploi
la région va investir 30 millions
d'euros pour sa construction
la nouvelle tour de contrôle estimé à 3
millions est en prise en charge par
l'état comme une bonne nouvelle n'arrive
jamais seule une convention vient d'être
passé avec la société airbus si ce lot
autrement dit des garages pour avion lui
sont désormais attribués pour faire
transiter ces appareils voici le tout
premier qui sera livré d'ici peu à son
acheteur aujourd'hui sur toulouse la
place est très rare et que batum airbus
est confronté à toulouse à
l'impossibilité de conduire d'avoir des
avions en stockage pour 15 jours ou
trois semaines et c'est ans la première
étape de ce que je décrivais tout à
l'heure sur le fait que château va enfin
être reconnu comme une brique très
importante dans l'industrie aéronautique
française est probablement européenne
depuis onze ans que la région a repris
en main les destinées de la
dur l'aéroport se développe doucement
mais sûrement et les efforts financiers
consentis par la collectivité son
existence ne sont pas surdimensionné
loin de là la stratégie qui est porté
par le président de l'ère encore la
direction d'aéroport est une stratégie
gagnante
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya la
montée en charge des activités qui en
termes de chiffre d'affaires font
progresser le niveau de chiffre
d'affaires nous quel est le besoin
d'avoir une intervention de millions
d'euros en terme de fonctionnement on
intervenait aujourd'hui comment le
chiffre d'affaires augmenté il ya une
baisse une ré un rajustement de notre
subvention d'équilibré dans les
prochaines années
l'aéroport châteauroux centre devrait
pouvoir maintenir son cas et renforcer
ses activités dans industrielle que
passager dans un contexte international
où le trafic aérien n'arrête pas de
croître
[Musique]